the Jaeger Corps traces its origins back
to 1785 with threats coming from the
neighboring countries of Sweden Prussia
and Great Britain Denmark created a
light infantry force initially they were
composed of hunters and woodsmen and
they continued to exist in multiple
different forms over the years until it
was remade into its current state in
1962 throughout the Cold War the jaegers
primary task was that of a long-range
reconnaissance unit with wide renowned
for their skills and parachute
operations following the 9/11 attacks
and the beginning of the global war on
terror
the jaegers were modernized to better
meet the developing threat of global
terrorism
the jaegers increased their proficiency
and counterterrorism skills while still
maintaining their high standards in
reconnaissance operations in 2002 the
jaegers were deployed into Afghanistan
as part of the Danish contribution to
task force k-bar during these operations
the jaegers took part in reconnaissance
observation capturing of high-value
targets and direct action raids on
Taliban and al Qaeda positions after the
reactivation of Team rainbow in 2015 one
Jaeger Corps operator was broadened to
bring her skills and expertise to assist
in the fight against terrorism on a
global scale
this operator was named No
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
codenamed nuke is an attacking operator
and team rainbow for reasons of national
security and currently active missions
NOx records are sealed at NATO
confidential security clearance but if
files have been released to six she
enlisted at the Army NCO school in
sønderborg and later enrolled at the
Royal Danish military academy where she
graduated with the rank of first
lieutenant with four deployments already
under her belt she underwent additional
Special Operations training and earned
two Jaeger Corps maroon beret with
skills and covert ops including combat
search and rescue direct action special
recon Arctic warfare and advanced
breaching she served her time in
Afghanistan and Iraq often and deep
undercover operations and alone behind
enemy lines through her efforts she
received commendations for eliminating
hostile radicals because of NATO's O&P
division she was recommended for rainbow
as one of its Deep Cover specialists
raised entirely by her mother the fear
of an almost tribal mentality towards
each other and our incredibly loyal and
protective furthermore they bond to
simulates that of best friends rather
than your typical mother-daughter
relationship while her true identity
remains hidden from the public
her fellow operators are aware of her
origins and have found it rather surreal
yet in spite of this it's been rumored
that the FIR identity were to be
disclosed to the public that a
potentially large scandal may arise it's
clear that her father and family are
notable individuals with a lot of power
and influence while she's always known
about her father and his family it took
a while before the family knew about
nook although they tried to facilitate a
bit of life for her
they made it extremely clear that
bringing light on her existence can
potentially cause major scandal for the
family
because of this you would think she may
halt some sort of resentment on her part
being hidden away like a revolting crime
however look it's relatively comfortable
with disagreement and enjoys quietly
serving Queen and country and everything
else that falls under the umbrella she's
an incredibly loyal individual and it
seems their outlook is very much rooted
in the betterment and sustainability of
others whether it be the soldiers of the
unit the country or her father's family
name and it's her ability to keep a
secret and maintain a facade that is
what makes her a highly capable
undercover operative milks gadget is the
ultimate form of stealth technology the
hell is a glove attachment which when
activated reduces her ambient noise
output and hides her image from opponent
observation tools cameras drones and
other gadgets will not only be unable to
register nukes presence but if footsteps
will be silenced this gadget works well
with looks at her undercover
reconnaissance skills and with this she
could be hiding behind every corner not
a huge amount to talk about on look
being that most of the information has
been redacted and all but still that
have been requested so who do you think
our dad is over the next day or so we'll
be dropping another video on worden so
look out for that one and always thank
you very much for watching and I'll
catch you in the next one Cheers